“This video is sponsored by Surfshark VPN,
if you’re in need of a VPN and want a great
deal on it, stay tuned till the end of the
video”
If you’re watching this video you’re probably
familiar with the story of the disasters and
also comical battle of Karansebes as it is
by far my most popular video to date.
However I ended the video on note of, we don’t
know what exactly happened, because quite
frankly, I did not have the time to go on
a rabbit hole hunt for some maybe nonexistent
primary sources about the battle.
But now, we’re back here well over a year
from my original video, and I have managed
to find some extra sources about the battle
that may shine some light on the actual events
that happened near Karansebes that September
of 1788.
So the story I presented at the start of my
first video is the main story that is presented
on most websites including Wikipedia.
To a certain extent that story is true but
widely over exaggerated.
For example the ridiculously high ten thousand
casualty count comes from an 1834 French publication,
which most certainly took some liberties to
portray the rival Austrian army as incompetent.
Continuing on from there, we can presume there
where many more second hand publications mostly
from rivaled Austrian countries taking large
liberties with the facts or even making up
new ones.
Such as the made up order of an artillery
fire directed straight into an Austrian camp,
or the fact that the Austrian military was
carrying a chest with the entire army’s
payroll, which we know wasn’t an Austrian
military practice.
Suddenly when looking at all of these made
up facts about the battle, it may start to
seem like the events at Karansebes, where
just made up by Austrian rivals as to diminish
their prestige in European politics.
However that is very unlikely, as there are
too many articles, from different countries,
talking about the same event.
Which if the battle would have been made up,
would be hard to coordinate between so many
different publications.
This also combined with the fact that it wasn’t
just foreign articles that talked about the
Battle of Karansebes, and there were Austrian
publications as well, means that it is highly
implausible that the story was made up.
In fact, the Karansebes story presented in
my first video, is a centuries long amalgamation
of second hand over exaggerated narratives,
of an event that most likely wasn’t as drastic
as it is made out to be today.
So to get away from this bias and over exaggerations,
records from the actual September of 1788
have to be consulted.
These aren’t as numerous as the second hand
19th century records, but there is enough
of them to make out what happened in Karansebes.
There are multiple none German or Austrian
sources from 1788, that talk about the Battle
of Karansebes, but they all seem to be reciting
the German and Austrian publications.
Over all, it seems like there are three main
writings that claim to have first hand sources,
or interviewed first hand sources like the
soldiers from the battle.
One of these writings are the official Ottoman
military accounts, which naturally can’t
give us a full picture, as they were on the
other side of the war, but can provide valuable
information.
Information like the fact that the Ottoman
troops were ready to engage the Austrian army,
only for them to find out in late September,
that the Austrians withdrew from the strategically
important Timiș-Cerna Gap, of which Karansebes
lies on the northern end of.
I mentioned this source in my first video
but what I didn’t mention was a different
Ottoman source, that accredits the Austrian
withdrawal, to the Austrian fear of facing
the terrifying Ottoman army.
However, this is obviously just Ottoman propaganda
at play, but the first source is still sound
giving us a solid ground to stand on, knowing
that the Austrians did in fact retreat from
Karansebes for some reason.
So now we have to look at the German and Austrian
sources claiming to have first hand records.
The first of these sources, the Politisches
Journal from Hamburg seems like a good place
to start, as it gives personal testimonies
from witnesses, and sights official Austrian
court documents.
It tells us that a skirmish did happen between
the Ottomans and Austrians at some point in
early September of 1788.
This skirmish most likely occurred somewhere
near the Timiș-Cerna Gap, as it says that
the “Kaiser ordered a retreat” via Karansebes
towards Temeswar.
During this confusing retreat, the local Wallachians,
which saw an opportunity to rob the Austrian
soldiers, started to spread rumours throughout
the army, that the Ottomans were in close
pursuit, getting ready to attack at any moment.
This turned the withdrawal in to a disorderly
panicked mess, during which two Austrian regiments
managed to run in to each other.
Due to the confusion and an expected Ottoman
ambush both regiments mistook each other for
Ottoman soldiers and opened fire.
They quickly noticed their mistake but the
damage was already done.
That is where the german source ends this
story, and continues on talking about the
bigger picture ramifications of the retreat.
The source doesn't mention if there were any
casualties or deaths but it is most likely
that there were at least a couple.
Going on from there checking the Austrian
article from Real Zeitung, there are some
similarities with the German source but also
some differences.
One of the similarities being that the initial
confusion was started by Wallachians, however
the way they started it, does differ from
the German source.
According to the Austrian source the panicked
confusion didn’t happen during the armies
retreat, but while it was encamped near the
town of Karansebes.
Apparently with the intentions of robbing
the camp, Wallachians started to yell “Turks!
Turks!”, causing a confusion and fear throughout
the camp.
The Austrian article continues on saying that
during the confusion, two regiments mistook
each other for Ottoman soldiers, and opened
fire, just as in the German source.
But the Austrian article does give more explanation
of why the soldiers miss took each other for
Ottomas.
Saying that the soldiers opened fire, only
after mishearing a “Halt” command from
one of the opposing regiments officers as
the Ottoman battle cry “Allah!”.
However after a few shots fired, the soldiers
quickly realized their mistake and stopped.
That is where the account ends, and the article
continues on talking about the military actions
of the Austrian army as they decided to retreat
from Karansebes.
So even though the Austrian source does differ
a little bit from the German source, the two
tell a pretty similar overarching story.
Showing us that the main underlying element
of the, “battle”, was a fear of an Ottoman
attack sparked by local Wallachians, after
which during the confusion two regiments accidentally
opened fire on each other, thinking the other
one was the enemy.
So even though today, the Battle of Karansebes
is remembered as a drunken scuffle turned
bad that in the end was responsible for ten
thousand casualties.
The true story is far milder.
However the truth never stops people from
embellishing the facts, especially when they
have a hidden agenda to push or an entertaining
story to tell.
“Speaking of an entertaining story to tell,
Surfshark VPN can be very useful weather you’re
trying to secure your sensitive data when
browsing the web or access geo-restricted
content, like those sweet Netflix and HBO
shows.
It can help you avoid price description or
get past internet censorship.
And to help you with all this, Surfshark VPN
is giving you 83% discount which unlocks the
best price on the market as well as one extra
month for free.
All you gotta do is either hit the link in
the description or type in Surfshark.deals/mlaser
and enter the promo code MLASER.”
Hope you enjoyed this explanation video, it
was a long time in the making and I admit
there are still certain elements I either
didn’t talk about for time’s sake or remain
unexplained or undefined due to the lackluster
sources I have managed to find but I just
felt like it was time to end this project
as I have already spent a lot of time on it.
Please consider subscribing and hitting the
bell button if you want to be notified every
time a release a video, which is once a month,
until then, my name is M. Laser stick around,
for History.